bonjour à vous merci d'être en direct
avec nous ce matin sur arte france
malgré la volonté des maillages macron
de faire de la finance un acteur de la
lutte contre le réchauffement climatique
on voit que les banques elles continuent
d'investir sur le marché des énergies
fossiles
comment vous l'expliquez alors à riscle
and financing ong pour qui j'ai fondé et
qui affiliés aux amis de la terre nous
avons analysé les politiques adoptées
par les acteurs financiers aussi
notamment les banques
ça s'appelle le scan de la finance
finance fossiles je suis désolé j'ai un
écho je m'entends ce que je dis bah
ouais c'est vrai que les ce petit
problème technique
est-ce que ça va à la main moi je crois
super donc comme je disais donc un
week-end fans ce qu'ils nomment jef kino
amis de la terre nous avons analysé les
politiques adoptées par les acteurs
financiers notamment par les grandes
banques françaises
ça s'appelle le scan de la finance
fossiles est ce qu'on a vu c'est que si
des efforts ont pu être faits sur le
secteur du charbon
tout reste à faire sur le secteur
pétrolier et gazier puisque les grandes
banques françaises ont adopté des
politiques qui sont extrêmement
lacunaires et aux touristes comme on a
pu le voir dans le reportage dé
financement massif aux entreprises qui
sont à l'avant garde de l'expansion des
énergies fossiles
donc qu'ils développent de nouveaux
projets pétroliers gaziers y compris
dans les secteurs les plus risqués on a
vu un reportage sur l'arctique on
pourrait penser aussi au gaz et pétrole
de schiste avec également des grosses
aberration par exemple bnp paribas est
la première banque à avoir adopté une
politique qui couvrent toute la chaîne
de production sur le secteur des
pétroles et gaz de schiste en 2017 et
pourtant bnp paribas est aussi la banque
qui a augmenté le plus ses financements
aux entreprises qui développent de
nouveaux projets de pétrole et gaz de
schiste aux états unis notamment parce
que cette politique là ne couvre pas les
majors pétrolières et gazières comme
shell est donc la solution aujourd'hui
c'est d'adopter des politiques qui
regarde le plan de transition 2
cesseront de ces entreprises est exclu
celle qui continue de développer des
projets qui sont incompatibles avec le
budget carbone qu'il nous reste
si nous souhaitons limiter le
réchauffement à 1,5 degré et ça c'est
pas seulement suivre les recommandations
des scientifiques
également suivre l'appel qui a été lancé
par l'aïeul agence internationale de
l'énergie ce mardi un appel très fort où
là il parle lequel les yeux a dit qu'il
ne fallait plus développer de nouveaux
projets pétroliers et gaziers donc plus
aucun nouveau projet de production c'est
très clair c'est très précis et il n'y a
plus d'ambiguïté
toutes les entreprises qui continuent de
développer ce type de projet ne doivent
plus être soutenu par les banques
françaises
et pourtant vous l'avez bien préciser
les investissements sont massifs dans le
cadre d exploitation de ces énergies
fossiles finalement le discours
politique est ce que c'est de la poudre
aux yeux selon vous les discours
politiques alors si c'est à promouvoir
justement la transition écologique
alors en effet on est des appels alors
de la part du gouvernement notamment
sont le ministre de l'économie et des
finances bruno le maire qui appelle tous
les ans maintenant depuis plus de trois
ans les banques grandes banques
françaises et les autres acteurs
financiers de la place de paris des
assureurs et les sociétés de gestion à
en faire plus pour le climat pour faire
de paris la capitale de la finance vers
sauf qu'on est uniquement sur des appels
à la bonne volonté des acteurs
financiers privés
on a pas du tout de volonté du
gouvernement de réguler de contraindre
la finance française qui est pourtant la
seule solution si on veut pouvoir
changer la donne dans le laps de temps
imparti aux limiter le réchauffement à
1,5 degré pour rappel en a seulement
neuf ans qu'il nous reste pour limiter
le réchauffement à 1,5 degré et donc il
faut absolument agir dès maintenant
à l'aune des conclusions du rapport de
l'agencé internationale de l'énergie
alors justement bruno le maire
ministre de l'économie a sondé à
plusieurs reprises les banques pour que
celle ci justement se tourner vers les
énergies fossiles
si ce n'est pas le cas finalement est ce
qu'il ya un vrai risque de sanction pour
les banques françaises
non c'est ça le problème aujourd'hui il
n'y a pas de risque de sanction pourrait
revenir sur l'appel de 2018 lancée par
bruno le maire à ce que la finance
française sorte du secteur du charbon
bruno le maire l'a reconnu lui-même
l'année dernière les politiques adoptées
par les acteurs financiers vont dans le
bon sens cependant tout le monde n'y est
pas tout le monde n'a pas répondu
présent à cet appel et certaines
politiques sont appliquées de manière
parcellaire à certaines activités des
acteurs financiers mais pas à d'autres
et pourtant face à ce constat il partage
bruno le maire n'est pas dans une
dynamique de contraintes pour les grands
acteurs financiers français au delà de
la contrainte sur tout les financements
aux énergies fossiles
on peut revenir bien entendu sur les
mesures qui ont été proposées par la
convention citoyenne et mesure qui
visait à déjà faire plus de transparence
sur les activités des banques françaises
et qui n'ont pas été acceptées comme de
nombreuses autres mesures par le
gouvernement la majorité en place et est
ce qu'on favorise pas ce que vous
faisiez parler à cette convention
justement citoyenne pour le climat est
ce qu'on favorise l émergence de fonds
vert du financement vert et est ce qu'il
ya un modèle que l'on peut suivre un
modèle ailleurs alors oui en effet il ya
plein de fond qui se développe avec des
petits noms les appels yes yes rsg etc
le problème c'est que s'arrête déjà une
ça reste une goutte d'eau par rapport à
la finance mainstream et on rajoute
finalement une couche de verre à une
finance qui continue d'aggraver le
dérèglement climatique
par ailleurs on voit bien qu'il ya un
problème de définition
aujourd'hui on a des grandes banques
françaises qui ont d'un claquement de
doigts
affirmer que 80% de leurs faux étaient
des choses le sg ça c'est le cas de bnp
ou 60% de leurs fonds étaient des fonds
mais j'ai pour crédit agricole lâche
amundi le sg ça veut dire quoi ça veut
juste dire que on a des gestionnaires
d'actifs qui intègre des critères liés à
l'environnement et au social et à la
gouvernance donc il se pose la question
lorsqu'ils construisent leur
portefeuille d'investissements si une
entreprise a une politique en matière
climatique cire elle s'est posée la
question des règles de parité au sein du
conseil d'administration si les
fonctions de président-directeur général
sont divisés ce genre de choses les
questions sont posées
après ça veut pas dire que si la réponse
est non on arrête d'investir dans les
entreprises qu'on a évalué et donc cette
intégration sg finalement elle et c'est
de la poudre aux yeux et elle ne permet
pas un changement profond de la finance
et sa décarbonation pour rester sous le
seuil de 5 degrés merci beaucoup a voulu
si mince je rappelle que vous êtes
directrice fondatrice de l' ong les amis
de la terre